crétin de cerveau ouais c'est le titre
d'une nouvelle série de vidéos que j'ai
décidé de consacrer à ce qu'on appelle
lé biais cognitifs et bien cognitif ce
sont des situations où des circonstances
où on commet des erreurs de jugement ou
alors on prend des décisions
irrationnelles et de manière un peu
systématique et ça peut aller assez loin
puisqu'on peut même se faire influencer
et manipulé pour lutter contre ces biais
cognitif qui peuvent nous pourrir notre
façon de réfléchir la première chose
c'est déjà d'en avoir conscience
d'où l'idée de faire une série de vidéos
dessus et le premier biais cognitifs
dont on va parler aujourd'hui on
l'appelle l'effet de halo
l'effet de halo c'est le fait
d'attribuer des qualités à quelqu'un
uniquement sur la base de son apparence
physique
en fait le terme vient de ces espèces
d'eaux réole qu on peignait notamment au
dessus des saints dans les peintures
médiévales
alors vous voulez un exemple simple
l'effet de halo et bien voici la liste
de tous les présidents des états unis
depuis le début du 20e siècle
et voici leur taille respective vous
trouvez pas qu'il ya un truc bizarre
bah ouais ils font quasiment tous plus
d'un mètre 80 la moyenne de leur taille
c'est un mètre 83
c'est un peu étonnant quand on sait que
la taille moyenne chez les hommes aux
etats unis c'est un mètre 75
la raison de sa c'est que le grand
public c'est à dire ceux qui votent
semble avoir une préférence pour les
grands candidats
probablement parce que le fait d'être
grand bassin en impose un ca fait leader
même si a priori ça va quand même pas
grand chose à voir avec la capacité à
gouverner un pays
et malheureusement faut savoir que ce
genre de différence on le retrouve pas
seulement pour les présidents des états
unis mais aussi au quotidien pour nous
dans le monde du travail
dans une étude qui a été publié en 2004
et des chercheurs qui ont montré en
étudiant 8500 personnes que les grands
sont en moyenne mieux payés que les
petits et les faits il est loin d'être
négligeable 1 toutes choses égales par
ailleurs l'impact sur le salaire annuel
c'est 300 $ par centimètre ça veut dire
que pour 20 centimètres de différence de
taille il ya en moyenne 6000 dollars de
différence de salaire à l'année et ouais
quand même
et comme vous pouvez vous en douter il
n'y a pas que la taille qui nous induit
en erreur quand il s'agit de juger les
personnes il ya aussi évidemment
l'attractivité physique et pour ce genre
de phénomène la source la plus
intéressante de données c'est le site
américain ok cupid okcupid c'est un site
de rencontres en ligne c'est un peu
l'équivalent américain de meetic si vous
voulez et je trouve que l'un des
fondateurs de quelques piques qui
s'avale christiane brunner c'est un féru
de statistiques et il s'est amusé à
utiliser la grande quantité de données
qu'il y avait sur son site pour essayer
de comprendre comment les gens se
comportaient en matière de rencontre
alors une époque sur le site canton
visualiser le profil de quelqu'un c'est
à dire une photo et puis un descriptif
on pouvait mettre deux notes une note de
physique et une note de personnalités
toutes les deux sur une échelle de 1 à 5
a priori s'agit de deux choses
complètement différentes 1 on a envie de
penser que le physique va plutôt se
juger sur la photo et que la
personnalité va majoritairement ceux
jugés sur le texte et ben regardons les
statistiques sur ce graphique chaque
point représente une personne qui a mis
son profil sur ok cupid avec en abscisse
la note moyenne de physique qu'il ou
elle a obtenu
et on a ordonné sa note de personnalité
et ce qu'on voit c'est que les deux sont
très bien corrélé c'est à dire que les
gens qui reçoivent une note basse en
physique vont aussi avoir une note basse
en personnalité et réciproquement ceux
qui ont une note élevée en physique
reçoivent comme par miracle une note
élevée en personnalité amusant non
alors quand on voit une corrélation
comme ça il faut toujours être prudent
je vais parler de quelques pièges
statistiques dans mon épisode sur le
paradoxe de simpson et dans ce cas
précis on pourrait imaginer que en fait
c'est le texte qui va influencer la note
qu'on va recevoir en physique ça serait
chouette non sauf que dans les données
de cupidon trouve des situations comme
celle ci par exemple cette jeune fille
elle fait partie des 1 % les mieux
notées en termes de personnalité et son
profil il est complètement vide et
ajuste sa photo pas de texte
ah ouais un sacré personnalité alors
comme chez ok cupid ce sont des gens qui
sont sérieux du point de vue des
statistiques
ils ont décidé de faire une vraie
expérience bien contrôlé pour voir quel
était le lien entre la note de physique
et la note de personnalités pour un
certain nombre de profils sont amusés à
l'affiché aléatoirement avec ou sans le
texte c'est à dire que la moitié des
visiteurs qui venaient voir l'un de ces
profils le voyait normalement tandis que
l'autre moitié ne voyait que la photo le
texte était effacée et ils se sont
amusés à comparer les notes attribuées à
chacun de ces profils dans les deux cas
suivants qui avait juste la photo ou
bien photos et textes sur ce graphique
chaque point représente un de ces
profils avec en abscisse la note obtenue
quand il y avait uniquement la photo et
en ordonnée la note obtenue quand il y
avait la photo et le texte est encore
une fois on voit une très belle
corrélation ce résultat il veut dire
qu'on va vous attribuez à peu près la
même note de personnalités que vous
mettiez du texte ou que vous en étiez
pas autant dire que la photo joue
beaucoup cpf c'est un bel effet de halo
alors si vous aimez ce genre de stats
vous recommande d'aller voir le blog de
okcupid qui compile tout un tas de
données de ce genre et notamment des
corrélations entre les notes que vous
allez recevoir ou le nombre de messages
et la manière dont est prise votre photo
c'est vraiment très intéressant
alors si ok cupid ça vous paraît pas
trop trop sérieux comme source rassurez
vous il existe plein de publications
scientifiques qui ont étudié de manière
systématique c'est effet de halo liées à
l'apparence physique et on va en voir
quelques années
l'étude fondatrice sur les effets de
halo elles datent des années 70 et vous
allez voir que ces conclusions vont à
peu près dans le même sens que ceux
qu'on vient de voir il s'agit d'une
expérience dans laquelle on a montré des
photos à un groupe de sujets et on leur
a demandé de juger de la personnalité
des personnes représentées sur la photo
en ayant juste la photo les sujets
devaient noter les personnes sur un
certain nombre de critères comme leur
sincérité et leur modestie leur
gentillesse leur altruisme leur sérieux
leur sensibilité ce genre de choses il y
avait 27 critères comme ça et on a
comparé les notes obtenues en fonction
de l'attractivité physique de la
personne qui était représentée sur la
photo est là bas sans surprise on a
trouvé que la note de personnalité des
personnes jugées physiquement attirante
était bien meilleure que celle des
personnes qui étaient jugées moyennes ou
bien peu attirante et au delà de ces
jugements de personnalités le biais
cognitifs liés à l'effet de halo il peut
avoir des conséquences assez graves et
un chercheur de l'université de toronto
qui a voulu étudier dans quelle mesure
le physique des gens nous influence est
quand on était juge dans un procès et
donc il a fait une expérience dans
laquelle il s'agissait de décider si
quelqu'un était coupable
sur la base d'un texte qui décrivait les
faits accompagné de la photo de la
personne jugée
évidemment l'idée était de regarder ce
qui se passe quand on garde le texte à
l'identique mais qu'on change
l'attractivité de la personne
représentée sur la photo et les gens
qu'on soumettait à l'expérience il
devait juger de la culpabilité de la
personne en la dotant sur une échelle de
0 à 5 0 c'était clairement pas coupable
et 5 c'était clairement coupable
et voici la moyenne des notes obtenues
on voit une sacrée différence de
culpabilité présumée en fonction du
physique de la personne sur la photo est
aussi pour la sévérité de la peine qui
sera attribué on observe la même chose a
un physique attirant et le juge sera
plus clément ah oui petit détail
technique
l'effet était beaucoup plus prononcée
quand un homme devait juger de la
culpabilité d'une femme que l' inverse
bah ouais et voilà c'était pour l'effet
de halo alors des biais cognitifs comme
celui ci il en existe tout un tas et on
les verra dans les épisodes suivants de
la série crétin de cerveau j'espère que
vous trouverez ça utile de les connaître
et puis aussi ça vous montrera que c'est
bien ils ont été étudié scientifiquement
par des chercheurs en psychologie et en
sociologie et ce sera une très bonne
occasion pour moi de vous montrer que
ces disciplines comme la psychologie ou
la sociologie qu'on a un peu tendance à
associer à la lecture de magazines de
comptoir en fait ce sont des vrais
science
il ya des chercheurs qui font des
expériences bien contrôlée qui adoptent
une démarche scientifique et qui font
des publications scientifiques à la fin
donc je ne manquerai pas de vous mettre
les sources
et voilà et donc prochain épisode
très bientôt merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo comme d'habitude pour ne rien
rater vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne n'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo
sur les réseaux sociaux pour m'aider à
faire connaître la chaîne vous pouvez
d'ailleurs l'actuel la chaîne sur
facebook sur twitter
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent le
soutenir sur type une femme plus merci
beaucoup à tous les types heures et vous
pouvez aussi aller jeter un oeil à mon
livre que j'ai sorti chez flammarion
merci à bientôt